so what I want to do here is try my hand
at running over DC's Flashpoint event
and what I want to do is instead of
somebody just covering the story I want
to I want to get a little more meat and
potatoes out of this and the reason why
I say that is yes flashpoint was a story
that was used by DC to launch the new 52
but a flashpoint was in and of itself
its own cohesive universe that had its
own backstories for a majority of the
characters it was very self-contained of
course it was a universe that ceased to
exist with the launch of the new 52 but
it was still you know it still had its
own history and the characters had been
shaken up in a lot of ways that made
them really intriguing from what we
normally saw and so what I want to do is
I want to kick all this off with the
story of whatever happened to Bruce
Wayne now to provide some context to
this I want to get into you know flash
Flashpoint issue number one and what
happens is we basically pick up with a
character of Barry Allen now the reason
why Flashpoint is such a big deal the
reason why it's so important is this was
really like the conclusion of Jeff
John's view of Barry Allen and the
reason why I say that is throughout
Barry Allen's entire history in DC
Comics you know before crisis on
infinite earth when he died during
crisis on infinite Earth and when he
came back during the events of final
crisis the one common theme in his life
was his mother Nora Allen it was the the
the Common Thread if there was any one
thing that he always always wished he
could do it was to go back and save his
mother's life but it was something that
he never did because he knew that
messing with a timeline would have
caused problems basically Jeff Johns
came back with flash rebirth not the
2016 DC rebirth but the original flash
rebirth which returned I guess told the
story of Barry Allen's return to the DC
landscape and Jeff John's retconned a
lot of things one of the most notable
things that he ret conned was the
character of eobard Thon if any of you
guys have been watching The Flash TV
show and if you were watching the first
the first season e barthon played a
villain who came from the future and
traveled into the past for the purpose
of going crazy and kind of killing Barry
but he was also his mentor and the
reason for that was within the comics
themselves eobard Thon had become
obsessed with Barry Allen he actually
went as far as to make himself look like
Barry Allen and his goal was to
basically be Barry Allen but when he
traveled into the past to meet Barry
Allen for the first time when he
realized that he had arrived after a
crisis on infinite Earth was over and
Barry Allen was dead he had driven into
insanity this was the same this was a
basically compounded by the fact that
eobard Thon after going to a museum
learned that he would be Barry Allen's
worst enemy and so instead of being you
know I guess fighting alongside his Idol
alongside his hero learning that he
would become the worst villain of Barry
Allen drove him insane then the result
was that under Jeff John's retcon which
is a retroactive continuity that's where
writers go in and change the status quo
of comic books Jeff Johns came in and
said that not only had eobard Thon
traveled into the past to meet Barry
Allen but once he became a villain once
he accepted his role as being a bad guy
he had basically engineered the
circumstances of Barry Allen becoming
the flash he was the reason why Barry
Allen's family had moved in the first
place he was the reason why Barry Allen
had been struck by chemical I guess I
had been doused in a certain mixture of
chemicals and struck by lightning when
he originally got his powers and the
most significant thing is he Fawn was
the one that killed Barry Allen's mother
now the reason why this matters is
because as we go over the course of this
Flashpoint series we'll learn that
eobard Thon was kind of anchored you
know if we looked at um at Barry Allen
as you know a ship that eobard Thon was
the anchor attached to the ship the the
chain basically being the timeline of
eobard thon's life in order for
eobardathon to become the reverse flash
Barry Allen had to become the Flash in
order for eobard Thon to want to become
Flash in the first place and so Barry
like ebarth's on going into the past and
making these changes was done to ensure
that he would come into existence now
this is something I'd like you to keep
in the back of your head because I know
it sounds a little weird but it'll all
make sense once we actually start
getting headlong into the main
Flashpoint event but picking up with
this uh of course we're just kind of
giving you know a little bit of the
rundown on Barry Allen's life we're kind
of giving a refresher basically by Jeff
Jones you know he talks uh talks to us
about how Barry Allen found love you
know about how he was able to make a
life of it for his own he was able to
fight along the flash family of course
Jesse quick Max Mercury Jay Garrick so
on and so forth Wally West you know he
fought alongside some of the mightiest
superheroes on the planet Earth and it's
just giving us context into who he is or
who he's been up to this point and what
happens is we switch to Barry Allen
waking up you know in the middle of an
office building now this is not uncommon
uh this is basically Jeff John's kind of
uh kind of you know pulling a a prank on
it so to speak kind of yanking the floor
from under us and the reason why I say
that is you know Barry Allen wouldn't be
a slacker by your standards of
measurement but because of the fact that
he is a superhero because he runs around
because he has so much going on it
wouldn't hurt to believe that he would
have to catch a break you know every
once in a while and this is what happens
of course the supervisor comes in and
his supervisor you know is is
disciplining him a little bit but Barry
Allen also hears that the villain
Captain Cold uh is running amok now
something I want you to take note of
here is they do not call him Captain
Cold they call him citizen cold and as
soon as Barry hears the name a citizen
called he learns that Captain Cold is
basically a hero in this reality as
opposed to being one of his most
formidable villains and so because of
this you know Barry is thinking that
maybe you know he's part of the Rogues
no one knows who the Rogues are it's
basically Jeff John's throwing things at
us extremely fast and so Barry Allen
goes to take off and he initially looks
at his hand for his ring which houses
his uniform and he doesn't see it and in
the process trips on the stairs and
falls down and when he does he comes
face to face with his mother Nora Allen
now this is basically Barry Allen's life
going into a tailspin because his
mother's alive here he doesn't know how
she's alive but he knows that she's
alive at the same time he was also
supposed to take her out to dinner for
her birthday and so this isn't as if you
know she's suddenly been brought back to
life she's been here all along and so we
as the reader are basically playing
catch up here we're trying to wrap our
minds around how something like this
could have happened and so as Barry and
his mother begin conversing with one
another what we also hear very doing is
trying to gain his bearings with his mom
asking about the Justice League asking
who Superman is asking who Batman is but
she doesn't know who the Justice League
are and she's never heard of Superman
she doesn't believe him when he says
that he's the flash but she has heard of
Batman now this is when we switch to
Gotham City and this is when I want to
start kind of breaking away from the
main Flashpoint story for a second and I
want to start getting into the story of
what happened to Bruce Wayne so the
following Batman here uh he's chasing a
villain you know to the you know on on
some kind of a bridge and asking where
the Joker's at now something else I want
you to take note of is how ruthless
Batman is here right now uh we expect
you know Batman to basically interrogate
people we expect Batman to not really
torture them but to certainly make them
feel as though they're in fear for their
life if they do not give him the
information that he needs his fear is
really his greatest asset but as this
character goes tumbling down and
actually seems to fall to her death
She's rescued by cyborg now cyborg
brings her back and basically keeps her
alive but he also begins to ask
questions of uh of Batman you know what
it is that Batman's doing why he's so
cruel now why it is he's so much darker
but there's also a little bit of uh of
recognition that this is something just
Batman's way that Batman allows people
to die that Batman himself actually
kills people but something else is that
he also chases villains to the same
alley every single time he pursues them
and this is something I'd like you to
take note of because what we do is we
switch into the actual story of whatever
happened to Bruce Wayne switching back
to Barry Allen and talking with his
mother because of the fact that things
are so radically different here one of
the first things he wants to do is
basically get with Iris West the woman
that he is that's that's part and parcel
to his life the one person who's really
more significant than anybody else and
the idea here is that maybe Iris knows
what's going on maybe Iris has an
understanding of how Everything's
changed but as soon as he gets to her
place of work as soon as he gets to the
Central City citizen to her news
organization he finds out that she's
actually in a relationship with somebody
else that she's not with him and so
again this is just another example of
how everything's kind of gone
cattywampus everything's gone haywalls
but we also learn that while Nora Allen
is standing outside waiting on Barry
someone says how nice to meet you alive
and well Mrs Allen now the indication in
here is that this is eobard Thon simply
by the draw by the the art that we're
given here but we're not told for sure
and before you know Nora Allen can
investigate any further Barry Allen
returns and simply asked to use her car
and so from here we switch back to
Batman with Cyborg and Batman is
basically greeted by all these different
these different superheroes the most
prominent superheroes as they exist at
the time uh of course citizen cold but
more notably than this is the fact that
we meet Shazam or what seems to be
Shazam now this is not Shazam as we know
him which is to say Billy Batson instead
these are basically the Shazam kids this
is an instance whereby it's Shazam
composed of a multitude of kids but
instead of him being Shazam being
Captain Marvel he's called Captain
Thunder and what happens is that these
kids all shout Shazam at the same time
and they become a singular being more so
than that we're also told that Wonder
Woman and Aquaman are at war with one
another now again this is not
information that's readily given to us
we're basically kind of being thrown all
this information really really fast by
Jeff Johns and he's kind of giving us
teasers he's kind of giving us you know
a preview of things to come and this is
one of the reasons why Jeff Johns is
such a good writer because he doesn't
just throw all the origins and all the
bases behind everything at you at one
time he basically what's your palette he
gives you a reason to keep wanting to
come back and so because of the fact
that Barry Allen is aware of uh you know
that or I guess he's told that Batman
does exist in his own you know in his
past as far as he remembers Batman
operates out of Wayne Manor and so he
travels to Gotham City he travels to
Wayne Manor he calls out for Alfred
Alfred's nowhere to be seen or found he
goes through descends down into the bat
cave and instead of finding these huge
super computers and you know millions
and millions of dollars worth of
equipment instead he finds a couple of
wooden desks he finds an office chair
some kind of graph and a picture hanging
on a wall and that's it you know of
course there's a gun there but there's
nothing there there's this Bruce Wayne
as we know him does not seem to exist
and so he's met with the arrival of
Batman and Batman immediately begins
interrogating Barry Allen but Barry
Allen keeps calling him out by the name
Bruce Wayne and the person responds by
saying that this isn't that he's not
Bruce Wayne that he watched Bruce Wayne
die and it's revealed to us that Batman
is actually Thomas Wayne and so what we
do here is we switch over to the story
to officially whatever happened to Bruce
Wayne instead of kind of teasing you
guys with it because I know you guys are
probably wanting to know by now we
switch over to this story where we
basically learn why it is that Thomas
Wayne is Batman
this particular explanation is given to
us in a story Batman Knight of Vengeance
and this is what DC did when they
launched Flashpoint because it was its
own cohesive Universe they gave us a
series of three issue tie-ins three
issue story arcs that covered a lot of
different things Aben soar Hal Jordan uh
it covered a citizen cold it covered a
lot of the characters that we've come to
see as either important characters
villain or otherwise in the role or in
the life of Barry Allen as well as more
notable Heroes you know Aquaman Wonder
Woman and so on and so forth what we
learned is that because Thomas Wayne
seems to have survived his son's death
he's grown very bitter but more so than
that he has basically turned you know
Wayne Enterprises into a giant
amalgamation of casinos so to speak
basically it's it's not Wayne
Enterprises as we know with technology
and different things like that it's just
a whole bunch of casinos and so because
of this business is a little strange
here but at the same time he's proven
himself to be wildly ruthless but also
home to some rather seedy individuals
the penguin basically makes his way in
uh in Wayne Casino Jim Gordon of course
functions in a lot of the same same
capacity but the main the main focus
here the main story here uh really seems
to be Joker emphasis is consistently put
on joker now this particular story was
written by Brian azarella it was not
written by Jeff johns but azarello does
a really good job of giving us a reason
to wonder who the Joker is because the
Joker is constantly being referenced
over and over and over again and so what
we do is we learn from Jim Gordon that
there have apparently been some children
who have been kidnapped by The Joker and
Batman's idea is to find out where they
are and of course to save their lives
and as he goes through during his
investigations he runs into Killer Croc
now this again is a huge difference
between some of what we've seen in the
traditional DC Comics and what we see in
Flashpoint because Flashpoint is
designed to be much darker than the
traditional run of DC Comics were shown
an instance whereby Killer Croc is
cannibalizing people and this is always
something that we knew and there have
been a few times where this is something
that DC sort of you know given Credence
to but we've never actually seen an
instance at least that I'm aware of
where he has people hanging around and
body parts missing because he's been
eating them and so the result is that as
he and Thomas Wayne started to get into
a fight with one another Thomas Wayne
does not hold anything back because he's
so cruel because he's so ruthless he
actually kills Killer Croc he simply
smashes him in the head with a machete
and that's the end of him and so what we
do is we also get a little bit of
explanation here we get a little bit of
backstory here in the sense that while
we are usually aware of the idea that
you know Thomas Wayne died in the
traditional DC Universe during the
shootout with Joe Chiller during the
robbery with Joe Chill instead it was
you know it was it was Bruce Wayne who
was killed by accident now this is
basically fleshed out over the course of
this particular three issue story arc
it's kind of given to us in sections but
the final scene of this first issue you
know of Batman Knight of Vengeance gives
us the Joker and it shows the Joker of
course is holding these particular
people hostage but the Joker looks
markedly different The Joker has long
hair the Joker's a little slender than
we would normally expect to see him and
so we end up picking back up again with
Batman's continued search of these
missing children now something else here
is that Selena Kyle is not Catwoman
Selena Kyle is not you know a cat
burglar as we come to know her instead
she's a quadriplegic she is stuck in a
wheelchair and completely has it's
totally unable to use the ability to
walk uh this is a market difference you
know it's it's not the most significant
aspect of the story but it's designed by
Brian azarella to show us how much
things have changed how drastically
different things are and so what ends up
happening is we pick up with the joker
as the Joker's basically taunting these
children and the Joker seems to have an
extreme I wouldn't say uh Obsession I
would say so much as a as an extreme
issue you know with children you know
the idea that the value of children
should not be something that exists
because in the end it'll drive you
absolutely insane this is basically kind
of Brian azarello throwing hints at us
you know on what it is that happened
with The Joker what it is that made the
Joker who they were in addition to this
we also learned that Selena Kyle is
basically operating as Oracle now and
this is also a huge difference here
because normally Oracle is Barbara
Gordon and instead it's Selena Kyle now
going through this it may have been that
I've missed something up to this point
but no explanation seems to have been
given on what happened to Barbara Gordon
but I would surmise that she probably
died at some point along the line or she
simply just never became bad girl but
again this may just be that I've missed
something uh maybe that I missed
something obvious uh if I did you know
feel free to post that down below I'm
sure a lot of you guys will but in the
end uh because of the fact that Oracle
serves a very very similar purpose to
how she does in the DC Universe the
traditional DC Universe she's a broker
of information she is the back end of
the technological side of the Batman you
know the Batman Mythos she gives you
know I guess in this instance Thomas
Wayne and Jim Gordon the information
they need in order to uh in order to
succeed in their campaigns and so we
learn that at least from Oracle where it
is that joker is holding these children
hostage now when Jim Gordon makes his
way into the room initially all he sees
is the Joker standing there with her
guns over top of this particular child
and when Jim Gordon breaks in and shoots
he actually ends up shooting the little
girl the girl that had been kidnapped
and so this again shows us how sadistic
and how dark this version of The Joker
Is but more so than that uh while while
this entire situation is being overheard
one Jim Gordon is killed he's stabbed or
I guess has his throat slit by The Joker
but two you know Thomas Wayne is
overhearing everything that's going on
he's also being sent abroadcast by The
Joker which it seems to be in the form
of a video or the very least in the form
of a picture it shows Jim Gordon being
killed but more so than that because of
what everything that's going on Thomas
Wayne reveals to us that the Joker is
actually Martha Wayne it's the mother of
Bruce Wayne and so what issue number
three does is it basically gives us the
events that have unfolded in the life of
Thomas and Martha Wayne after the death
of Bruce Wayne and what we learn is that
when Batman arrives you know when Thomas
Wayne arrives he basically you know this
this girl being dead he does what he can
to you know console the boy he does what
he can to try to keep this girl alive
even though she's pretty much gone but
the backstory that's given to us is that
because Bruce Wayne had died Martha did
not initially crack she showed early
signs you know of sort of losing her
sanity but it wasn't an immediate thing
instead it was a slow progression in the
sense that Thomas basically kept telling
her you know you've got to try to get
past this we all have to try to get past
this we all have to work on this as best
we can and what he says is the one thing
he misses more than anything else aside
from Bruce Wayne is Martha smiling but
she doesn't really seem to be snapping
out of this psychotic break she doesn't
really seem to be getting past this you
know this Insanity you know that that
she's experiencing and so what we're
told is that Thomas Wayne uses his
resources uses his money to find the
location of Joe Chill by going through
some less than Savory you know sources
and in the end once he locates Joe Chill
uh he basically beats him to death with
his bare hands and so the result is that
when he comes back when he comes home to
his wife Martha he tells her that Joe
chill's dead that he's killed Joe Chill
but when Martha turns around she's given
herself a glass smile the traditional
Joker smile where he has his uh has his
cheeks cut and she says that that she's
finally happy now that she's finally
smiling and so this is basically the
psychotic break you know of course uh
Thomas Wayne had her committed to an
insane asylum and this was her downward
spirals who officially becoming the
joker now while this backstory was given
to us as you guys probably noticed we
were also seeing Martha fighting her
husband in real time and in the current
moment you know and again he tries to
convince her he tries to get her to come
back now this is the big difference here
because in in the normal DC continuity
by the time the conflict comes around
assuming that you know we we sort of uh
skip past the origin story of The Joker
or the perceived origin story with the
killing joke and we pick up with you
know uh Batman's normal encounters with
the joker by that point in time he was
long gone any semblance or any chance of
returning to normalcy was out the window
you know the Joker was who he was and he
was going to be the Joker for the rest
of his life uh with Martha Wayne it's
not that way it seems as though her
current role as a joker is not that far
removed from when she was simply just
Martha trying to deal with death of her
son and this is apparent in the fact
that Thomas Wayne tries to talk her back
to normal he tries to bring her back to
normal as she's initially resistant but
what he says is and this is actually
kind of of skipping forward a little bit
in the sense of the main Flashpoint
story after conversing with Barry Allen
Thomas Wayne is basically told by Barry
everything Barry remembers from his own
life that Bruce Wayne was the one who
lived Thomas Wayne was the one who died
along with Martha and that Bruce Wayne
became Batman fighting crime in Gotham
City and this is what Thomas says that
you know of course assuming that Barry
Allen is to be believed that Thomas
Wayne has the ability to go back and to
make things right he he basically gives
Martha the way the situation should have
played out he says that it should have
been you know both Martha and Thomas
that died and Bruce Wayne that lived and
it seemed as though he was connecting
with her for a moment it seemed as
though he was you know she was starting
to understand that she was starting to
return but in the end her Insanity kicks
back in again and she basically runs off
and in the situation when Thomas Wayne
is chasing her she ultimately falls down
a hole which ironically enough uh is
actually the whole that Bruce Wayne
seems to discover in order for him to
become Batman you know she falls down
the hole and she basically dies she she
falls to her death and that's the end of
Martha Wayne as the Joker but but this
is basically the story of how Thomas
Wayne became Batman so if you guys
enjoyed this uh you know drop a like hit
the sub button become part of the Rob
Corps and leave a comment uh let me know
what you guys think about this
particular story whatever happened to
Bruce Wayne
um let me know what you guys thoughts
are you know because in truth assuming
that there's interest in this you know
assuming that there's there's some
measure of popularity I wouldn't mind
going through and kind of covering the
flashpoint Universe how characters
changed what happened with different
people so on and so forth so picking up
with uh Flashpoint part two we initially
start with Slade Wilson with Deathstroke
now this is a very interesting set of
circumstances because we would expect to
see a Deathstroke assassinating people
or something along those lines but
instead Deathstroke's actually a pirate
now to be honest here I really like what
Jeff Johns did with Deathstroke I really
like the idea of Deathstroke being a
pirate somehow It just fits I mean not
necessarily my because Deathstroke is is
cold-hearted but because in a lot of
ways Deathstroke is just a loner but
he's also kind of a guy you don't mess
with and you could easily see him you
know being a modern day pirate which
again I think works perfectly but what
we also know is that because they're
Pirates they're basically just searching
the world over for Salvage they're just
looking for uh they're just trying to
live essentially they're just taking it
day by day and what they're doing is
they're using the powers of a character
named sonar now sonar is is actually
interesting and this is why I think Jeff
Johns did a great job with Flashpoint
because sonar was a minor Villain at
best you know He was largely a Green
Lantern villain and he had the ability
to manipulate sound but instead of him
being a guy that just kind of lays waste
to things and fighting alongside or
maybe even being a hero instead he's
just being used as an object here he's
basically serving as a way for Slade
Wilson to scan underwater and see if
there's anything worth getting now this
is effectively torture for sonar just
because of the fact that in order for
him to use his powers effectively or to
be forced to use his powers effectively
he's being electrocuted by another
character named electric eel and so
again this is just showing us how
ruthless and how harsh life is in this
Flashpoint society and that individual's
characters are just kind of being torn
to pieces and just being forced to live
miserable lives but during their uh
during their scouting Mission they come
across another ship and when they see
its flag they realize it belongs to a
character named Warlord the problem here
is that the ship and everybody on it has
been absolutely massacred and this is
this is shown To Us by the fact that
Europe seems to have been entirely
flooded now this is why we have you know
Slade Wilson running around as a pirate
but we also learned that his ship has
been set upon by Aquaman now this is
where things get a little crazy here
this is where things get a little weird
initially we were just kind of left to
our own devices to figure things out but
with Aquaman being so ruthless we
actually switch back to Gotham City with
Barry Allen and Thomas Wayne now again
for those of you guys who are just
getting caught up those are guys who saw
the last video this part of the video or
this part of our discussion takes place
uh prior to the adventure between you
know the main Flashpoint story in the
last video and our segment on what
happened to Bruce Wayne and so this kind
of fills in the gaps for those of you
guys who are waiting for this bit of
information to come around because Barry
Allen realizes that this is Thomas Wayne
he kind of he's kind of shocked here
Thomas Wayne again doesn't know who
Barry Allen is from his perspective this
is just a random guy who showed up who
discovered his location in the bat cave
and he doesn't know what his intentions
are but Barry is actually able to talk
sense into Thomas Wayne even if Thomas
is only a little bit skeptical here but
what also happens is Barry's mind is
kind of being fractured in the sense
that his memories of the way things used
to be and his memories of the way things
are now are starting to converge in the
sense that he's losing his former self
what we're told is that at some point
along the line Wonder Woman and Aquaman
had basically engaged in war with one
another that Wonder Woman had led a
blitzkrieg in tearing London into pieces
and that uh Aquaman had flooded the
entirety of Europe now there is a tie-in
that explains what happened here there
is an explanation on what it is it took
place it kind of provides the back story
here which again you know I'm all for
going over for if you guys are
interested or if you guys just kind of
want to stick with the main story for
what it is it's fine by me but because
of the fact that Barry is starting to
experience you know this emergence of
memories what Jeff Johns has basically
done here is he's given us a time frame
he's basically said that if things don't
go back to normal after a certain amount
of time Barry Allen will lose everything
that makes him who he is and he'll
basically be stuck in this timeline
remembering how things are as opposed to
the way things should be and so during
this bit of recall so to speak his ring
fogs out falls out of his pocket now
again this is what Barry Allen houses
his uniform in you know whenever it is
he's on the Run whenever he's on the
move he always has his ring there so he
can pop it out for easy access do
whatever it is he needs to do and then
go back to being his normal self and
this is what he tells Thomas Wayne he
says that he has the ring whenever he
needs to be a superhero and he'll prove
to Thomas Wayne that he's the flash even
if he doesn't have his powers he'll
prove to Thomas Wayne who he is by
virtue of showing him his Flash costume
but when he uses the ring and when he
brings his costume out it's actually the
costume of reverse flash eobard Thon and
Barry Allen immediately comes to the
belief comes to the conclusion that
eobard Thon has somehow screwed with
time now this is interesting here
because as far as we know eobard Thon
was trapped in the speed force you know
during the end of flash rebirth we don't
we don't have any reason to believe that
eobard Thon is involved here but because
of the fact that the speed force is
outside of space and time a person who's
there could access any point in time
this is compounded by the fact that
eobarthon has the ability to manipulate
time which is why he was able to go back
through and screw up the life of Barry
Allen leading him to become the flash in
the first place all of which of course
was covered in my last video In the End
Barry Allen basically makes the case
that this is all eobarthon's doing the
eobard Thon had somehow gone into the
past and changed things and because
things have been changed Barry Allen
basically sees himself as the one person
that can make things the way that
they're supposed to be now of course he
gives Thomas Wayne a bit of his
backstory he gives Thomas Wayne an
explanation that eobard Thon who was
lived in the 25th Century became
obsessed with Barry Allen traveled into
the past realized that he was going to
be a bad guy which broke his sanity and
then went further into the past and
began engineering the circumstance
chances of Barry Allen's life that led
him to becoming the flash including
switching chemicals around so that when
Barry Allen was struck by lightning he
would become the flash uh killing Barry
Allen's mother Nora Allen forcing Barry
Allen's family to move all the things
that led up to that particular moment
were all done by eobard Thon and so
Barry Allen makes the case that in order
for things to go back to normal in order
for Bruce Wayne to live and Thomas Wayne
to die that that Thomas basically has to
help Barry Allen get his feedback he has
to help him become the flash again and
so what we do is we switch over to
London which has now been christened his
new thimiscira Under the control of
Wonder Woman and we see a soldier who we
don't initially know who he is going
through and trying to keep himself alive
against the forces of the Amazons trying
to trying to keep him dying to be quite
Frank but in the middle of this conflict
he's initially he's eventually captured
and taken prisoner by Wonder Woman Who
uses her lasso of Truth now again the
lasso of Truth basically forces those
who use the lasso or who were ensnared
in The lasso to tell the truth and it
does have his weaknesses which we can
get into at a later day once we get
closer to the Wonder Woman movie but the
last of Truth is used on this soldier
who reveals himself to be Steve Trevor
now again this is just Jeff John showing
us another instance of how things have
changed because Steve Trevor was
basically Wonder Woman's liaison to the
world of humans when she first arrived
but more so than that he was her first
major love interest among normal society
and so to see them as bitter enemies is
a huge difference it tells us that most
likely Wonder Woman never left Amazon or
never left the mascara in the first
place even if she did things didn't turn
out quite the same way now we're not
told if Steve Trevor played a role in
that but I would surmise that because
Steve Trevor was Wonder Woman's way of
segwaying in a normal society because he
showed her so many different things
because he showed her how to conduct
herself as a normal person he was
basically able to make her uh human you
know to take her away from this uh this
life that she had previously LED and
allowed her to become a stronger
character because now she was able to
balance her life into mascara as well as
her life as a regular superhero which
eventually in the new 52 gave way to a
romance with super man himself but what
we also learn is that Steve Trevor is
here for the purpose of rescuing Lois
Lane now the reason for this is that
Lois Lane is one of the greatest
journalists in the world at the moment
and she had basically gone undercover
into London to gather as much
information as possible for cyborg who's
working on behalf of the US government
in order to allow him to organize an
attack and to basically subvert the
forces of Wonder Woman now it's
something that you may have noticed here
is something you may be scratching your
head about is if Lois Lane is in London
and she is in danger why hasn't Superman
rescued her yet and we will actually get
to that later on in this story but
instead we switch back to Gotham City
and this is basically kind of like a
Jimmy rigged experiment What's Happening
Here is uh Barry Allen and Thomas Wayne
have rigged a uh really in an execution
you know and an electrocution chair uh
in order to put Barry Allen in the
situation where he'll be dousing the
same chemicals that he was when he first
got his powers and then he'll be struck
by lightning during a rainstorm and
he'll become the flash again at least
that's their hope the problem with this
is that when this happens when this
lightning strike takes place and when
Barry Allen is hit by lightning he
doesn't become the flash instead he's
just covered in scars he is absolutely
fried and so it seems as though there's
no way for Barrett Allen to become the
flash again at least that's the
information that's given to us at the
conclusion of this second issue by Jeff
johns but with that being said if you
guys are enjoying this so far uh drop a
like hit the sub button become part of
the Rob core and leave a comment I gotta
tell you guys flashpoint's one of the
best stories that I've read in a long
time because for me you know as a comic
book fan there's nothing I love more
than seeing alternate realities where
things just go really bad
and I don't mean to sound cynical I
don't mean to make it sound like I'm a
terrible person but I think we all like
that I think we all like to see what
happens when superheroes go bad or when
the world just descends into chaos we
love dystopian stuff if you guys love
dystopian stuff like post a comment tell
me tell me why it is that you love
Flashpoint so much is it because it's
just a different take on characters or
is it because things are just really
really bad because that's my reason I
just love seeing things really really
bad so as we get into Flashpoint part
three what we do here is we backtrack
for a second and we're gonna cover the
story of Wonder Woman and the Furies now
this particular story gives us the
events or at least one part of the
events that led up to the conflict
between uh Wonder Woman and Aquaman but
more so than that it tells us why Europe
is in such disarray now Dan Abbott was
the one that gave us the story and he
actually did it in a really really good
way he did a really awesome job with
helping us come to grips with everything
that's happened so far what we're told
is that with Arthur Curry at a young age
instead of falling in love with Mira and
marrying her as his Queen instead he had
met Wonder Woman now the two of them
assume we just met each other by virtue
of Their Own Adventure and their own uh
celebration and and in truth this is
basically dad abna telling us that
Arthur Curry is the stand-in for Steve
Trevor instead of Steve Steve Trevor
being the first man that Wonder Woman
meets and eventually falls in love with
instead she ends up falling in love with
Arthur Curry now they're both attacked
by a sea monster or at least she's
attacked by by sea monster and Arthur
Curry comes to her rescue but because of
the fact that she is a character that
you know is strong in her own right with
regards to being on Newton mascara and
because the atlanteans don't usually
deal with surface dwellers in a lot of
ways their love was kind of forbidden it
was a very Romeo and Juliet sort of
situation in the sense that instead of
it being their parents who were against
the uh the union between Wonder Woman
and Aquaman instead it was actually a
couple people it was Artemis on the uh
from from nutha mascara and it was
Aquaman's brother orm who were against
this now in terms of why they were
against this and why they instigated
this war in the first place this will be
covered as we get further into
Flashpoint simply because I don't want
to give certain things away but the fact
remains that both Artemis and orm had
instigated what appeared to be an
assassination on Wonder Woman at the
hands of an Atlantean and so a sphere
was thrown and queen hippolyta had
basically seen the spear coming at her
daughter and dived in the way the result
was that she had died and in return
Wonder Woman believed that it was an
Atlantean now this is later later on
reveal to actually be Artemis herself
who had thrown the spear and Aqualad had
stepped in I guess you know the sidekick
you know Garth the sidekick of Aquaman
had discovered what was going on but in
the confrontation uh he was effectively
killed you know when he was thrown off a
balcony and so with the body of of Garth
showing up here when the when because
Artemis had not been found in the end it
was believed by the Amazons that the
atlanteans were engaging in war they
were attempting to use this Union
between Arthur Curry and Wonder Woman as
a means to subvert the mascara and take
it over in its entirety and so the
result is that the uh the atlanteans are
kicked off the island and the Amazons
began the process of going through the
traditional three-day ritual uh to mourn
the loss of their Queen now this puts
both Aquaman and Wonder Woman in a tough
situation because in truth they are king
and queen first and their hero second
and what I mean by that is throughout
their entire history really more so with
Aquaman than with Wonder Woman Aquaman
has always been in a situation education
where if it came down to the fact that
Atlantis was being attacked and the
Justice League was being attacked at the
same time he would choose Atlantis over
Justice League almost every single time
just because he's a king first and he's
a hero second with Wonder Woman it was
never really the same way traditionally
she would always stand up for the
mascara but she always recognized that
her role was more significant to the
world than it was to her people and so
she was always in a tough situation
because she routinely had to choose
between her own people and you know the
I guess the Earth as a whole as humanity
and the relationships that she had
forged alongside the other members of
the Justice League in Flashpoint it's
not that way because of the fact that
she is now the queen but because of the
fact that the perception is the
atlanteans are trying to wage war and
trying to take over the mascara her
loyalty is entirely to her people
especially considered the fact that the
Justice League does not exist here and
so because of this during this morning
phase she's constantly getting you know
receiving words of poison from Artemis
at the same time you know Aquaman is
constantly receiving words of poison
from his brother orm and they're
basically exceeding conflict between the
two of them they're seeding war between
the two of them now again they're not
necessarily wanting to do this and what
ends up happening here is Aquaman
actually travels to the mascara for the
purpose of trying to mend this Rift
between the two of them it's really an
olive branch trying to make the case
that yes the death of Queen hepalida was
very tragic but it was not committed by
atlanteans there's something else going
on here but because the Amazons are in a
state of grief because virtually all of
them except for Artemis are unaware of
the fact that it was actually a ploy
that was going on that is designed to be
a ruse Artemis basically uh calls in an
attack she calls in a huge conflict
between the atlanteans and the Amazons
and the result is that again in the eyes
of Wonder Woman the atlanteans are
engaging in yet another instance of
treachery and so because of the fact
that the the atlanteans seem to be
winning the war because of the fact that
Wonder Woman's not aware of of Artemis
sabotaging the Amazons themselves to
make it look like the uh the atlanteans
are winning in the end Wonder Woman
makes the k case that they need to
abandon release she's kind of forced
into position to abandon the mascara to
blow up the island and take refuge
elsewhere and this is exactly what she
does she basically sets off the or I
guess releases the restraints that are
normally used in the mascara and allows
it to explode now what I mean by this is
for those of you guys who don't know and
at least it's really cool because it's
given to us by Dan Abner as he gives us
this explanation the thinnest Kira lives
exists on a uh on a volcano and the
Amazons harness the geothermal energy of
this volcano in order to provide what
they need for survival the result is
that restraints are needed in order to
keep the volcano from going active and
exploding what Wonder Woman did is she
removed these restraints and so as the
atlanteans are fleeing for dear life the
uh the island is exploding all around
them now from here Dan Abbott fast
tracks a few things he actually gives us
information from the eyes of a reporter
named Jack Ryder and what he tells us is
that after the the destruction of the
mascara its remaining citizens took off
in Fleet and they basically went to
Europe they went to uh to the United
Kingdom to England as refugees they
looked to England to house them to give
them a place to stay temporarily until
they could reform the mascara the
problem is that England said no and so
Wonder Woman decided to take it by force
she literally launched an invasion of
England she presented herself to
Parliament and said and basically
Justified her case saying that we are in
need of a home your home is as good as
any it now belongs to us and this
basically gives us a darker side of
Wonder Woman but it also tells us even
if indirectly behind the scenes that
maybe everything that she's doing isn't
things that she wants to do she's doing
them because she has loyalty to her
people her goal is to make sure that the
mascara has a home and if that home
means taking the home of somebody else
then that's what she will do as a result
she also began Gathering some of the
most powerful women in DC Comics around
her calling them nefurious now this is
basically Dan Avnet paying a little bit
of a tribute to the history of Wonder
Woman in the sense that the furies are
actually an organization or a group that
exists under dark side and is composed
of his most powerful women they are
forced to be reckoned with and there was
actually a story where Wonder Woman was
inducted into the furies against her
will for a time and so this is basically
Dan evidence saying that even if we're
not going to see Darkseid even if we
won't see his Furies we will see some
tribute to the concept of the theories
themselves now while this is going on
you know while this conflict is taking
place we pick back up with Aquaman and
again he's being put in a hard in a hard
spot here he's being put in a situation
where he's being asked to do things that
he doesn't really want to do the idea is
that because of the fact that the
Amazons have wiped out famous hero
because they have engaged in war because
both Atlantis and Amazons are at war
with one another the idea is that the
atlanteans need to repay in kind they
need to do something to show the Amazons
that they are not to be pushed around
but they cannot simply be walked over
and so the idea is to basically lay
waste to the mascara by destroying
England and so while Aquaman doesn't
want to do this he also asks the
question where his wife Mira is located
and so what we do is we switch to the
port of Dover in England in new them as
Kira and what happens is Mira makes her
presence known mere era basically
attacks the Amazons along with a host of
Atlantean soldiers now while the
Atlantean soldiers are holding their own
against the Amazons Mira and Wonder
Woman engage in a fight with one another
and when they do the fight is actually
pretty Swift there's really not much of
a contest here Wonder Woman comes out on
top and she cuts off the head of Mira
and because of this because Mira is now
you know or at least because she was
betrothed to Aquaman he takes this as
the utmost threat he takes this as
something that cannot be called back and
so he effectively declares open war on
the Amazons for the first time in the
midst of this conflict and in doing so
orders the entire sinking of Europe at
the hands of the Atlantean super weapons
having said that as we continue our
discussion with the main Flashpoint
story itself we pick back up again with
Thomas Wayne and Barry Allen now I do
apologize if I keep saying Bruce Wayne
Uh incidentally it's just I'm not used
to saying Thomas Wayne Batman
it kind of throws me off kilter whenever
I have to say that I kind of have to
pause and make sure that I didn't
actually say Bruce Wayne but if I happen
to do that in the future of these videos
don't hold it against me it's just it's
something I'm not used to saying Thomas
Wayne Batman it's just kind of crazy to
me but that's one of the reasons why
this story is so cool because it just
gives us different depictions of
characters that we've come to know and
love and so with uh Barry Allen having
been electrocuted due to the fact that
he was trying to uh get his powers back
the lightning storm simply just frying
his body uh where Thomas Wayne takes him
back to the bad cave tries to nurse him
back to health in the End Barry Allen
wants to try again not from the
perspective of Thomas Wayne this is
absolutely crazy because in his mind a
guy just showed up on his doorstep said
he was the fastest man alive got his
powers that way because he was dealt
with chemicals that electrocuted and
when he tries to repeat the process he
just ends up getting fried again but
because of the fact that Barry Allen
seems to have information on the way
things are supposed to be he can't help
but believe bear he can't help but
believe that if there's a single chance
that Bruce Wayne lives instead of dies
that he has to help him here now again
what Jeff Johns also does is he reminds
us that things are beginning to fracture
the things are beginning to change that
because of the fact that this new
reality is totally different in the
sense that Aban sewer is the Green
Lantern instead of Hal Jordan which if
you guys are interested I can do the
story whatever happened to Hal Jordan uh
because of the fact that these memories
are beginning to fragment that Jeff
Jones is reminding us they're on a
timetable here the time's running out
that they have to hurry up and this is
basically Barry Allen giving us this
information saying that time is running
out they have to do something and so in
order for for Bruce Wayne to live in
order for things to be turned back to
normal you know Thomas Wayne has to help
Barry get his powers back and so what
they do is they go right back to the
rooftop again and they go through the
process of dousing Berry and chemicals
yet again and when Barry is electrocuted
this time it works and his powers of the
flash are restored to him and so what
happens is that while Barry is
recovering because of the fact that his
powers of the flash Grant him enhanced
healing in the sense that he can recover
from you know flesh injuries much faster
than a normal human can we transition to
nutha mascara in London and we pick up
with Lois Lane now this is actually
really cool because this is basically
Jeff John's beginning the early stages
of rolling you know Wild Storm
characters non-main DC characters over
into these DC's landscape those guys who
don't know
um DC Comics is only one facet of the
that big side of the Comic-Con we've got
Wild Storm you've got vertigo which is
their adult oriented imprint you've got
a lot of different uh different
characters that hail from that side of
the spectrum you know under the larger
umbrella of DC and the purpose of the
new 52 was to take those characters and
roll them over into a single continuity
and this is exactly what Jeff Jones is
doing during this entire situation where
Lois Lane is trying to you know get back
into contact with Steve Trevor even
though she doesn't know at the moment
that he's been taken prisoner by the
Amazons what she does is she comes face
to face with the resistance who's led by
grifter now grifter is a wild storm
character we don't really need to go
super in depth into him again I think
what we've said so far about you know
Wild Storm and so on is is enough to
suffice our explanation but more so than
that what this tells us is that the
citizens of England didn't just roll
over it wasn't as though you know if the
Wonder Woman showed up in invaded London
and they just kind of gave up and walked
away instead there's small pockets of
resistance the problem here is they're
effectively going up against forces who
are wildly powerful Wonder Woman having
power equivalent to that of Superman and
the result is that they were leg waste
to almost immediately you know England
was conquered almost right off the bat
and so they do the best there can but to
be honest here they're basically
fighting a losing battle and so what we
do is we jump back to uh to Thomas Wayne
and he's looking you know at Barry Allen
because of the fact that he has enhanced
healing because of the fact that he's
recovering from his injuries extremely
fast this gives Credence to the argument
he's been making that things are not the
way they're supposed to be and so what
Barry Allen does is he uses his super
speed he grabs different chemicals and
so on and so forth and he makes a new
Flash costume super fast which isn't
really supposed to be something
significant here it's just sort of Jeff
Johns giving us that you know yes things
are getting back on track yes the story
is moving forward yes we're gonna start
seeing things return to a state of
normalcy sort of moment kind of the The
Tipping Point so to speak of the story
at this point where things are going to
start transitioning in favor of everyone
and so the one question Barry Allen has
is where is Superman because Superman is
the one character who could literally
change the entire tide of Battle
Superman can go toe-to-toe with Aquaman
and Wonder Woman and defeat them both as
well as give Humanity something to
Aspire to and so his question is is
Superman's not here then where is he did
he simply just not arrive on the planet
Earth does his rocket never show up here
and so both he and Thomas Wayne start
going through old footage and we
actually get some really cool uh
explanation here on a couple things one
of the things that Jeff John shows us or
tells us is that at some point in the
past Hal Jordan had piloted an
experimental test plane the reason why
this matters is because that's how
Jordan became the Green Lantern
originally he was piloting a test plane
he was chosen by the Ring of the dying
Aben soar and he was inducted into the
Green Lantern Corps the rest is history
uh Jeff Johns doesn't really give us any
more than this again this is covered in
a uh in Italian but what we're also told
is that they're the rocket of Superman
did crash land in Metropolis and so
again Barry Allen's tells Thomas Wayne
the Superman is the most powerful person
on the planet and so if they can find
Superman assuming that he's here if they
can locate him and Assuming he's not a
bad guy have him fight on their behalf
they can quite literally save the world
and so while Thomas Wayne says that he
doesn't know where Superman is he knows
a person who does and so we pick up with
Barry Allen and Thomas Wayne meeting
with cyborg who again is working on
behalf of the US government and he has
access to all their information and so
what he says is yes he will help them
find Superman but only under the
condition that they fight alongside him
in trying to take back the world and so
what they do is they transition to new
metropolis and when they get there they
basically travel to a military base
underground and this military base has
been in existence since Superman first
arrived on earth once they get there and
they open up this giant room they find
Superman but he's nothing like the one
that we know instead he's emaciated he's
very thin and he seems like a normal
human being now the reason why this
happened and we can actually kind of
skip over the time a little bit here the
reason why this happened was because
when Superman first arrived instead of
being discovered by the Kents and
instead of being adopted and taken under
their wing where he would eventually
become you know Clark Kent and
eventually become Superman instead he
was immediately taken by the federal
government and when he was he was held
in stasis with red light which kept his
powers from emerging because he never
experienced the yellow sun he's lived
his entire life underground inside this
bunker being held as a prisoner and
being used for experimentation and so
once they break in once they freeze
Superman this is strange to him because
he's never seen people like this before
he's never seen people like him but more
so than that or Barry Allen this is wild
because he'd never seen a Superman that
looks like this before he's always seen
a huge confident wildly powerful
Superman and so while they're trying
while both you know Superman and Barry
Allen and the heroes are trying to come
to grips with the situation the soldiers
break in and they basically begin the
process of running them off and so while
they escaped while they are able to get
out the Superman comes into contact with
a yellow sun for the very first time
time and he of course begins to fly he
starts showing his display of powers but
he's not in control here he's not he
doesn't have total control over his heat
vision he doesn't have control over his
flight he's learning these things for
the very first time now he Masters them
pretty fast at least in terms of his
ability to fly but he basically when
he's asked by you know by Thomas Wayne
when he's asked you know to basically
save them to get them out of there he
takes off and he immediately heads out
for the Sun and so as this issue comes
to an end we're basically left with
cyborg Thomas Wayne and Barry Allen at
the at the wrong end of guns from U.S
soldiers and it seems as though they're
about to be taken prisoner so as we
continue our discussion on the
flashpoint storyline from DC Comics what
we do now is we pick up with the story
of whatever happened to Hal Jordan now
this is actually in my mind one of the
best stories or one of the best you know
tie-ins to come out of the flashpoint
event what we do is we're kind of fast
tracked you know on this uh this history
of Hal Jordan something that kind of
amazing about this is that this was was
actually written by Adam schlagman this
was not written by Jeff Johns and the
reason why it kind of amazed me is
because you know Jeff Johns is the Hal
Jordan guy he's the Green Lantern guy
whether or not he wants that to be his
legacy the fact remains that he did such
a good job on the Green Lantern that
those who are familiar with Hal Jordan's
mythology uh really look at Jeff Johns
as someone who's synonymous with the
Green Lantern Mythos but what Adam
schwagman does is he sort of fast tracks
a lot of the things that go on and he
basically sort of shows us the the
history of Hal Jordan in the sense that
his father was a pilot um that he wanted
to be a pilot because he looked up to
his father he met uh Carol at such a
young at such a young age um you know
that that in the end when his father
died it sort of shattered his life and
he ended up going to work you know for
Ferris Air Force Base under Carol Ferris
and he proved himself to be a very
prodigious pilot this is very much
um indicative of what we would expect to
see with his character the issue here is
that once everything started to change
and once we ended up in a scenario where
the atlanteans and the Amazon started
Waging War against one another then it
stopped being an instance where you know
Hal Jordan was an experimental test
pilot and instead started being an
instance where he was basically training
for military action now he was not
really part of ongoing military action
per se it's so much as it was always a
background it was always a backdrop it
was always at some point in time he will
get caught up in the conflict uh in some
form or fashion now one of the things
that Adam Swagman does here is he throws
a lot of the uh the Mythos of Jeff
John's Green Lantern run in passing even
if it's not necessarily overt for
example because both Carol and himself
are fighter pilots you know they are
effectively partners and she I guess her
her cover name or her code name is
sapphire which of course is a homage to
Jeff John's Reformation of Carol Ferris
as becoming one of the Star Sapphires in
uh in the Green Lantern reboot and so
what ends up happening here is in the
midst of this entire conflict of course
he's attacked by uh by shark man and
shark man is defeated you know using uh
using the the tactics of both uh Hal
Jordan and himself Carol but even then
it comes under scrutiny just because of
the fact that they were they were using
tactics that weren't necessarily
approved by their superiors but the fact
remains here that in the midst of this
conflict once it's over uh Hal Jordan is
set upon by the arrival of Aban sewer
now this is where things change wildly
because in the in the regular DC Mythos
Aventura had arrived on Earth and he was
basically dying and the result was that
with his dying breath he sent his ring
forward to find a replacement and
Flashpoint that does not happen instead
Hal Jordan actually saves the life of
Aban sewer and so the indication here is
that how Jordan does not become a Green
Lantern instead I've been soar and this
is actually covered in Italian was sent
here to the planet Earth for the purpose
of finding the White Lantern uh Ring of
Life basically finding the the White
Lantern entity and the idea was that
Aventura was only going to be here
temporarily instead Avan sir actually
stayed here and became one of the heroes
that fought alongside cyborg to
basically try to return things to his
state of normalcy under the direction of
the US government and so while this
happened while Avan sewer went along
ended his own thing as the Green Lantern
on Earth the Hal Jordan ended up taking
an indirect approach and what I mean
here is that while he was fighting or at
least observing alongside the US
military he was set upon by several
Amazon forces and because of this
because the situations seemed to be
growing out of the control of the
governments of the world Hal Jordan was
tasked with dropping the Green Arrow
nuclear bomb on England basically in an
attempt to wipe out the Amazons or at
the very least to subvert their ability
to continue a forward campaign the
problem with this is that Carol Ferris
does not like this idea now one thing I
want you guys to also take note of here
is that the two are very much in love
with one another but Hal Jordan hasn't
quite popped the question he hasn't
hasn't quite brought himself to do that
yet and so against the wishes of Carol
Ferris and under the direction of
President Barack Obama in this story he
has assigned the task of dropping the
snook now he tries to talk to Carol one
last time he tries to communicate with
her one last time or at least to give
her you know his side of the opinion but
in the end it results in a fight between
the two of them and so while they are
able to reconcile to a degree it's not
to the point where they make amends it's
not to the point where they are able to
to basically apologize appropriately now
this is a very big deal for Carol Ferris
and the reason why is that once they set
their attack upon the Amazons and the
forces are laid waste to uh in Swift
order Hal Jordan drops the nuclear bomb
and when he does he actually dies in the
explosion he dies in the process and so
while Carol is able to make it back
while Hal Jordan does give her her his
last goodbyes before he officially
perishes in her aftermath in her
grieving she's met with a package that
was that had belongings uh you know for
Hal Jordan and as she goes through him
she finds a letter that he had written
to her which is actually something Adam
had been covering over the course of the
story if you've been you know following
along with the various panels that we've
seen then the idea was basically Hal
Jordan writing her a love letter you
know telling her that he loves her he
just never really bring himself to say
that he loved her and could never bring
himself to give her her in engagement
ring and so she's kind of left dealing
with this grief as best she can and this
is why Hal Jordan never became the Green
Lantern because he died bravely in a
nuclear explosion in an attempt to wipe
out the Amazons now something I want to
point out here and this is one of the
reasons why I was a little hesitant
about doing the uh the Hal Jordan story
is because it really coincides with this
next part of the story that we're going
to talk about but it's also one of the
reasons why I chose to do it now that's
simply because of the fact that with the
flashpoint Story the tie-ins uh the each
of the three part times sort of followed
along with the main event itself and the
third story usually told what was
happening in issues four and five of the
flashpoint event leading up to this
great big huge final battle that was
going on and so what we do here is we
pick up with uh with Shazam we pick up
in Fawcett City now again Shazam or at
least I call him Shazam is actually
Captain Thunder in Flashpoint Shazam is
not just Billy Batson Shazam is a
culmination of kids all of whom share
some aspect of the Shazam power and when
they all say Shazam at the same time
they merge into a singular being and the
idea here is they're kind of unsure
whether or not they should fight against
Wonder Woman and the president is on the
camera on on TV right now telling them
that those individuals who are able to
fight should fight that the only way to
hold off the Amazons and the atlanteans
is for what's left of humanity to rise
up and fight as a singular group and
take on these two forces and rid the
world of them because at this point in
time reason and logic doesn't stand a
chance against them there's really
nothing they can do to go against the
forces of both Wonder Woman and uh and
Aquaman the only way to basically save
the world is to get rid of both of their
regimes in their entirety and so what we
do is again we switch over to Hal Jordan
and this again is of course you know
just the segment where it's showing us
that Hal Jordan's gearing up to drop the
nuclear bomb again you know of course we
covered this a little bit earlier but
more so than that we switch back to
Metropolis now this of course comes as
Fallout from Barry Allen and Thomas
Wayne and Cyborg attempting to rescue
Superman but because Superman had
basically taken off into the sun after
seeing the Sun for the very first time
they're really sort of left to their own
devices now they're not entirely
powerless of course Barry Allen has
super speed cyborg has his different
gadgets and uh and Thomas Wayne is very
Adept in terms of his ability to fight
against them uh the help here that they
don't expect comes in the form of a girl
named Emily soon but she's referred to
as element woman now this is interesting
because element girl is more or less the
same kind of character as metamorpho now
metamorpho is a long-running character
in DC Comics he's been around for quite
some time and he gained his you know
Powers through mystical artifacts and so
on and so forth but the fact remains
that he's able to change the shape of
the structure of his body to more or
less manipulate his body for a multitude
of different ways element girl is the
exact same way she's an elemental but
she can manipulate her body based on a
multitude of different substances and so
she's she's a very strong character the
problem here is that she's also insane
and this is actually something that Jeff
Johns sort of gives us here what he says
is that she according to Thomas Wayne is
absolutely nuts she's really Harley
Quinn esque in terms of her level of
insanity not necessarily that she's
going nuts and wanting to kill people
but in the sense that she seems to be
well for all intensive purposes be a
socially awkward person and the result
here is that she when when the president
sent his message out telling people that
they need to band together they need to
fight together as a singular team and
she took that literally to mean that you
know she was going to be on a team with
them now they're not necessarily against
it and the reason why is because if they
don't have Superman they need whoever
they can get they need whoever they can
rally to their side to fight against the
forces of Aquaman and Wonder Woman and
so they basically end up bringing her
along but during this process Barry
Allen continues to have these uh these
glimpses I guess reformations of his
memories from the way they used to be to
the way things are and he's continuing
to lose himself and so again Thomas
Wayne has brought along a series of
injections that will help Barry Allen to
fight along or fight against these you
know modifications to his memory but
again this is just Jeff John's telling
us time is of the essence and so what we
do is we switch over back to the uh to
the Shazam kids and they're again
continuing to debate whether or not they
should get involved but in in the end
the idea here is that once you know once
Barry Allen won cyborg wants Batman once
element girls show up here they
basically tell them you guys have to do
something they are wildly powerful in
terms of their abilities but what uh
what Barry Allen also does is he shows
them who they are from his timeline and
his reality Billy Batson is the one kid
who was Shazam you know not all the
other kids that were there it's simply
just Billy Batson more so than that he
had a Shazam family in addition to that
he also fought Black Adam is one of his
most notable villains but at the same
time he was also an equal to Superman in
terms of sheer strength depending on
what era of comics that we're talking
about but the legacy of Shazam the
legacy of Captain Marvel is a very rich
one and a very powerful one and in his
reality in Barry Allen's home reality
the main DC Universe that we're used to
Shazam wouldn't have stood idly by if
there was a way for him to save the
world he would have done what he needed
to do when it needed to be done and so
what we do is we switch over to a news
broadcast which shows the fact that Hal
Jordan has been killed in the new clear
explosion that we had talked about where
he is no longer you know part of the
landscape and this is a huge deal for
Barry Allen because he didn't know where
Hal Jordan was he didn't know what was
going on with Hal Jordan but the fact
remains that this is yet another
casualty and the case that they make
here is that Hal Jordan was just a
regular guy he was a regular pilot
willing to put his life on the line for
the purpose of saving the world the
problem here is that Thomas Wayne
doesn't necessarily agree with him and
Thomas Wayne makes the case that people
because of who they are because of what
they've done they sort of deserve to die
he's willing to cast them aside but in
the eyes of Barry Allen in the eyes of
cyborg this is not okay that everyone
has to fight that everyone has to do
what they can to save the world because
even when it seems like all hope is lost
in the face of such overwhelming odds
even when it seems like there's nothing
they can do that they have to do
something and so what happens is they
grab the Shazam kids they grab Thomas
Swain they grab element girl everybody
they can find who's willing to fight and
they launch this sort of last-ditch
effort on the shore scores of nutha
mascura they launched this last-ditch
effort you know between the atlanteans
and the Amazons and we have a full
contingent of what we consider to be
some of our most prominent Heroes some
of our favorite Heroes but at the end
they're only able to do the best they
can they're only able to hold off things
to a certain degree and that was Shazam
something to point out here is that the
forces of Wonder Woman and these these
guys didn't know that they were composed
of kids and their mind Shazam was just a
superhero now the last time that Wonder
Woman and Shazam fought Wonder Woman
came out on top but when enchantress
shows up she says they're just kids
playing as grown-ups and so what she
does is she forces Shazam to return back
to his form of kids and this shows us
how cruel the Amazons can be when they
turn their swords against Billy Batson
as a child and they kill Billy now the
reason why this matters is because the
Shazam kids cannot become Shazam if one
of them is dead and so while this
happens while Barry Allen is watching
all these events unfold while he's
watching watching absolute Calamity
takes place he's met by eobard Thon and
eobard Thon simply says look what you
did
but with that being said we are going to
uh
actually you know what we're not going
to bring this video to an end
uh my editor Gordon is going to be a
fantastic editor and he's going to put
the other half of this story in here so
we're going to get to issue number five
because I love Cliffhangers guys you
guys know I love Cliffhangers but I
cannot I cannot leave things I cannot
leave you guys like this I can't leave
you guys hanging with with this so so
what happens is with eobarthon here and
with forces of Wonder Woman and the
forces of Aquaman and Cyborg and his
forces are fighting one another Jeff
Johns begins to shift our focus our
Focus stops being on everything that's
going on and it starts to become starts
to focus on Barry Allen and kneeboard
Thon and this is why I say this is like
the continuation this is the finale of
Jeff John's run this is where it all
stops you know this is the end of his
view on Barry Allen because this brings
us the final Conflict or at least what
seems to be the final conflict between
eobard Fawn and Barry Allen what happens
is from Barry Allen's perspective eobard
Thon screwed up the world eobard Thon
messed everything up but there's also a
little more to this for those of you
guys who had read flash rebirth I don't
mean the current one I mean the one from
when Barry Allen first reappeared in the
DC landscape after having died and
crisis on infinite Earth a lot of
retconning was done there but at the end
of that story eobard Thon seemed to be
stuck in the speed force it seemed as
though he was trapped there and there
was no way he was going to be able to
escape what we're told is that over the
course of his existence in the speed
force he was always trying to find a way
out and Barry Allen was the one who
engineered that what eobard Thon tells
us is that Barry Allen himself was the
one who had screwed up the past that
Barry Allen himself was the one that had
changed everything that because Barry
Allen always had this desire to save his
mother's life that because Barry Allen
always had the desire to save Nora that
he had done that he traveled into the
past and he saved his mother's life and
when he did he altered time he altered
reality now because of the fact that
there was no flash there came a point in
the history of society when people
needed someone one who was super fast
when they needed someone when when there
was just a pivotal moment when Barry
Allen was needed and because he wasn't
there things just began to take a
downward spiral uh into absolute
Insanity leading the universe to the way
it is now in addition to this eobard
Thon himself was quite literally
anchored to Barry Allen because
iobarthon was obsessed with Barry Allen
by virtue of the fact that Barry Allen
was a Flash and eobard fawn went into
the past to meet Barry Allen and ended
up driving himself insane when he
learned he became a villain the two were
tied together you know Barry Allen
became a flash which led to eobard Thon
which led to eobard Thon traveling into
the past and ensuring his legacy by
influencing the events that would lead
to Barry Allen becoming the flash but
because of the fact that eobard Thon was
stuck in the speed force at the end of
The Flash rebirth story when Barry Allen
went into the past and saved his mom's
life the ramifications the changes in
the timeline did not affect eobard Thon
which effectively freed him from being
tied to Barry because what this did is
it created a paradox if Gary Allen never
became the flash then how could eobard
Thon have come into existence and so
because of this ear Marathon was free to
do what he wanted who is free to to to
travel throughout the Multiverse and he
had done this the entire time from the
from the point at which this new
universe was created this new universe
came into existence Thon just began
traveling around Thon just began going
around and analyzing everything looking
at everything and being slightly
entertained by what was happening now
while Thomas Wayne does intervene while
Thomas Wayne does try to help Barry
Allen as best he can he's totally
outmatched he's nowhere near the speed
that he needs in order to defeat eobard
Thon but what happens is that things end
pretty quick in truth it's really just
eobard thon's gloating that cost him
everything this is really the downfall
of of Thon it's the fact that he allows
himself to be so arrogant is the fact
that he allows himself to get caught up
in his successes that he doesn't even
take the time to consider that he might
fail and so while he's gloating while
he's towering over Barry Allen while
he's making fun of him while he's
relishing in his success Thomas Wayne
sneaks up behind him and stabs him
through the chest with a sword thus ends
the legacy of eobard Thon and so what
happens here is while all these forces
are fighting one another the resistance
shows in grifter makes his appearance
known by fighting against you know the
the forces of of Aquaman and Wonder
Woman and so on and so forth but while
all this happens suddenly Superman makes
his appearance known now again this is
not the Superman that we're used to this
is not the Superman that we know but he
does have all the same power that he did
and the reason why is because when he
took off he basically just spent his
time drinking in the energies of the sun
drinking in all that solar radiation and
so while he's not physically buff he's
every ounce as strong as we would expect
him to be and he shows it when he
single-handedly takes out both Aquaman
and Wonder Woman now initially it seems
as though he's on the verge of
destroying them he's going to wipe them
out but as things begin to change as
reality begins to reach a point whereby
it seems like all life is going to
destroy itself Barry Allen comes to the
realization that because he's the cause
of this because he's the one that
screwed up reality he has to go back in
time and he has to change it he
literally has to go let his mother die
he has to let her go and so Thomas Wayne
gives him a letter to give to his son
Bruce assuming everything goes back to
normal and Barry Allen starts running as
fast as he can to the point where he
breaks the time stream and when he gets
back when he goes he ends up running
into his mom but he has to go back even
further and he basically keeps reliving
all these different memories now he does
visit her he does tell her that he has
to set things back to normal he does
tell her that he's going to have to let
her go that she'll die and she says it's
okay because she'll be with his father
but as he continues running as he keeps
running back as far as he can he
eventually encounters himself he
encounters him going back in time and
saving his mother's life and so I know
it seems a little confusing I know it
seems a little weird but this is where
DC's reset this is where DC's reboot
comes into play when they launch the new
52. what they did is they basically
introduce a character named Pandora now
we don't really need to go into her
wildly but what what happened here is
with the actions of Barry Allen because
he had gone back and changed the past
when he goes back a second time and
allows his mother to die this creates a
whole new universe and it basically just
allowed DC to grab their Wild Storm to
grab their vertigo to grab their main DC
timeline to grab all these different
versions of their characters and mold
them into a singular reality which gave
birth to the creation of the new 52
timeline and so what this does is this
sets things back it sets Barry back to
the moment when he first woke up and of
course as he comes too uh he realizes
that the flashpoint Universe had
happened he realizes everything that
took place but he also realizes that
things are now back to normal and so
what he does is he races back to the uh
to the bad cave to Bruce Wayne and
initially he's a little confused he
actually asks are you Bruce Wayne and
Bruce says yes of course and he gives
Bruce he tells him everything that
happened and he gives him a letter to
Bruce written from his father and for
the first time that I've ever seen in
the history of DC Comics Bruce Wayne
actually he cries because for him this
is a huge thing to be able to have some
measure of information from his father
is a huge deal but more so than that
because Barry had talked to Thomas Wayne
while he was in that universe and told
him what Bruce Wayne became it was a way
for Bruce Wayne to know that his father
was proud of him that his father was
proud of everything he had done
everything he had accomplished that he
was able to restore normal he was able
to avenge them without killing people
without reverting to such a a gruesome
person away that Thomas Wayne had done
and so anyway that brings an end to the
flashpoint story uh if you guys enjoyed
this let me know because I got to tell
you Flashpoint is probably one of the
best damn stories DC's had in a long
time even now with DC rebirth Flashpoint
still stands a test of time as one of
the best stories I've ever done but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section drop a like if you
enjoyed this and uh yeah I will catch
you guys later
peace
[Music]